well I think for me the importance of
the Himalayas is is the extent to which
it dominates that part of Asia really it
controls the climate it's a major area
of cultural and biological diversity and
it's also of course the coming together
of many interesting and fascinating
countries in that region and what
happens in the Himalayas has an impact
on the whole of that part of Asia and
particularly of course on China and
India in particular but also Southeast
Asia so the Himalayas is a kind of a
pivotal place I think for for an
academic institution that's that's
interested in the in the future of that
part of Asia and those two great
economies in particular the Himalayas is
right at the center of all of that the
Yale School of Forestry environmental
studies has had a really strong and deep
and ongoing relationship with countries
in the Himalayas not only through our
ongoing work with colleagues in Bhutan
but also through long established
programs in the poor particularly
professor birch and the work that he did
there but also with colleagues in India
and in indeed the the long relationship
that the school has had with forestry in
the Government of India based out of
dehradun and our alums who are
associated in that part of India so so
in a way this is a very natural part of
the world for the school of Forestry and
environmental studies to be engaged with
and because it plays to our long
historical strengths it plays to a real
concentration of our alumni and what I
like in particular this is that it
crosses borders it's not a relationship
with a particular country its
relationship with a region and I think
that's really very very important and of
course that historical relationship with
with the Himalayas
also plays out in the present day I mean
we have students right now from India
students from Bhutan students from from
the poor and they're an active and
vibrant part of our of our Himalayan
program and what's wonderful is that
they'll go back to the region and
they'll join our existing alumni body in
that region and they are helped to make
things happen on the ground and the
school is very much concerned with what
happens on the ground what happens in
practice our PhD students from the
region are masters students from the
region even interacting with
undergraduates here Yale who are from or
have an interest in the region so
there's a lot of concentration on the
Himalayas here which i think is a really
really great thing I think from from the
opportunities that I've had to visit the
Himalayas what's been underlined to me
is the kind of the complexity of the
region the kind of cultural complexity
but also the huge challenges they face
in terms of infrastructure but also the
rapid changes that are going on in that
region just the same as they're going on
it everywhere else around the world it's
wonderful for me to see our alumni
engaged in different parts of these
processes it was fantastic for me to
have my eyes opened to some of that some
of these issues many many different
kinds of issues biological ones physical
ones cultural ones and I think that that
really the Himalayas is a wonderful
place where we really can bring these
three ideas of environment livelihoods
and culture and bring them together to
really understand what's happening in
the region
you